on freine avec la main c'est cette mainl
c'est laquelle c'est la droite donc on
freine avec la main droite et la main
gauche un peu mais surtout la main
droite ces enfants verriers roi seront
les conducteurs de demain s'ils ne sont
pas encore au volant la sécurité
routière s'apprend déjà commencez à
éduquer les enfants jeunes c'est comme
une langue étrangère plus vous l'prenez
jeune plus bah cette langue elle va elle
va vous rentrer dans la va vous rentrer
dans dans dans dans le cerveau et puis
vous allez après ce sera un automatisme
ce qu'on inculque aujourd'hui aux
enfants c'est la sécurité la sécurité
routière et ils en parlent aussi à leurs
parents et ils voient les défauts de
leurs parents et aujourd'hui c'est c'est
c'est très très productif savoir manier
son vélo comprendre la signalisation ou
encore se rendre compte de l'impact de
l'alcool sur la perception les plus
jeunes ont pu découvrir les
comportements à adopter pour les freins
par le monsieur tout à l'heure il
m'avait dit faut faut pas freiner avec
tes pieds moi j'avais l'habitude de
freiner avec mes pieds j'ai appris de de
quelle sens allit tourner en repoint et
après j'ai je suis allée sur
l'ordinateur pour faire le quiz des
enfants et j'ai appris s'il fallait
rester sur le trottoir à des moments ou
s'il fallait courir sur la route quand
on était pressé cette journée était
assuré par les agents de la sécurité
routière de la préfecture et de la
police municipale des ateliers ludiques
pour faire baisser les chiffres de la
mortalité routière 36 personnes ont
perdu la vie sur les routes du
département depuis le début de
l'année